hi hello uh i'm
massachusetts from national cancer
center in japan
today i will talk about the
transcriptome analysis of breast cancer
clinical specimens with
long read sequencer
there are many tumor types in which
structural variations
of chromosome abundant for example
there are many structural variations svs
in chromosomes in a type of breast
cancer
that is a triple negative breast cancer
tnbc
tnbc comprises 15 to 20 percent of
all breast cancer and is defined by a
lack of
estrogen and progesterone receptor
expression
and the absence of rb2 gene
amplification
which encodes human abdominal growth
factor receptor 2
part 2 whole genome sequencing
of tnbc revealed abundant svs
that is caused by homologous
recombination deficiency
previously we have reported the results
of integrative whole genome sequence
uh integrated genomic analysis
of tnbcs in which
whole genome sequencing and short
read transcriptome sequencing were
performed
as shown in this slide svs
in the representative chromosome
in tnbcs are shown by
colored arches and as you can see
the chromosome of tnbcs are heavily
affected by various
svs
so what is the consequence of these
various
svs uh these
rearranged genomic regions transcribed
and if they are rearranged
[Music]
what is the characteristics of these
of the transcripts derived from such
rearranged genome
to address these issues we studied
the analysis of full length transcript
bomb analysis
with isosig using long read sequencer
sql
when we started the analysis the
length of raw read
is about i was about 20 to
30 kilo base pairs long
and that is much shorter than the
current
state of art and then
[Music]
that exceeds 150
kilobytes per long
so we prepared the
cdna libraries for the icc analysis
cdnas are
generated by reverse transcription
the generated double standard
cdnas is ligated with
helping dna
adapter dna oligos with helping
structure
and starting from the helping loop
dna polymerase goes through
this circular structure
repeatedly assuming that
[Music]
the transcript is 2000 base pair long
and raw sequencing read
is 20 kilobase pair long
in that case it turns out that the
transcript is
will be sequenced 10 times
that greatly improve the accuracy
and the consensus sequence is called
sakura circular consensus sequence ccs
so again double standard dna
is made circular with helping
adapters and
sequenced repeatedly to generate
accurate sequence information
in the isothic analysis
[Music]
ccs with similar sequence
were clustered together to generate
isothic consensus with that represent
[Music]
one transcript and as a whole they
generate they comprise
the transcriptome as shown in the
right panel
i have to mention that we used
isosix ii algorithm when
we analyzed these uh data and
and i think two is uh slightly different
from the current isosex3 algorithm
uh but the general principle
is common to both
in this slide and the actual sequences
of representative gene sox9as1
that we detected
in this project presented
socks 9as1
is encoded next to and opposite of
sox9g
at the top of the slide reference
sequences
registered in gen code are presented
and as you can see in the middle
we detected various uh
isoforms that spans
uh socks981 and
locus and the neighboring
zero five one ac0515 two genes
so uh we detected not only
uh x9 and s1 isoformed
as forms but also uh the read through
transcripts at the bottom uh
the actual sequences that we
verified by piece
sangha sequencing of pcl amplicons are
presented
so in this way we have
identified hundreds of thousands of
isoforms that are not registered in
gencode so
the question is how to analyze these
isoforms
in general abnormalities in
cancer genome were
detected by comparing the
detected sequences with reference
sequences
in this case however there are no
corresponding reference sequences to be
compared with or mapped against
and of note the
novel isoforms that do not have
corresponding isoforms
the most interesting targets of analysis
is a useful tool to analyze isosceles
it classifies isosceles based on how
they differ from reference sequences
for example full splice much
fsm isoforms the isoforms
in which splice junctions
perfectly match with those of
reference sequences
in complete splice match ism isoforms
composed of
[Music]
known splice junctions but they
do not have complete set of splice
junctions
novel in catalog nic isoforms
contains novel
splice junctions but they are composed
of
non-splicing donors and known splicing
acceptors and in contrast
novel not in catalog and in ic
isoforms have
novel splicing donors or
novel splicing acceptors
and
by using skunk as shown in the
right graph many nic
or and then and and then many nic
and nnic isoforms
were detected
but however
we have no we had no idea how to proceed
with the analysis after this
classification
uh now isosix3 algorithm implements some
quantitative processes but when we were
analyzing this data
our data there are no suitable tools to
quantitate isosic risk
by the way in general long read
sequencing technologies are used for the
construction of reference genome
genome sequences of various organisms
so we consider that
isosceles can be used as a reference
you can build a reference
transcriptome using the information
obtained from the samples to be analyzed
from the target samples
and once the
transcriptome is created
you can use that transcriptome
to make comparison between samples
or between subtypes also you can make
use of
various analytical tools
that are now available
so we created a pipeline
in order to
that can merge isosceles
from multiple samples
at first isosceles with similar
sequences
should be merged to reduce redundancy
iso by merging iso degrees with similar
sequences that was supposed to be
derived from
uh identical transcript uh
we can obtain uh we can obtain catalogs
of trans non-redundant
transcripts for individual samples
and they are further combined
to generate cohort wide transcriptome
as shown in panel b
once you have uh and uh
generated uh cohort white transcriptome
is further subjected to
scant filtering to remove artificial
transcript by random forest algorithm
once you and now that you have
a new transcript on
you can evaluate you can
you can measure the number of
reads number of isosceles for individual
iso degrees
in addition by mapping shortly
sequencing data
against the reference transcriptome
you can evaluate the expression of genes
using algorithms developed
for the analysis of short read
sequencing data
and for example you can identify genes
with
differential expression or genes with
differential
transcript usage and we named
this pipeline as
much sample along with transcriptome
assembly musta
and now it is available at github
we evaluated the performance of
differential transcript usage detection
dtu detection with
simulation data we tested
five conditions
of any ic rate of
[Music]
0.0 and i see ratio of 0.0
0.25 0.5
and 0.75 and 1.
even under the condition of nic ratio
of 0.0 that means the
all the dtu isoforms
uh fsm full splice much
isoforms and none of the dtu isoforms
nic isoforms even under that condition
performance of dtu detection with most
derived
transcriptome is higher than that with
mr uh higher than that with a gen code
transcriptome and as
the nse ratio increased
the performance of dt detection with
gencode transcriptome decreased
as shown in the dashed line
or black line
on the other hand the performance of the
detection with
mr derived transcriptome
remained constant showed stable
precision
and recall so these data indicate
that
you can evaluate the
differential usage of isoforms
including isoforms not annotated
that is not annotated by creating
a transcriptome using the information
obtained from the target samples
this venn diagram shows the represented
representative data of dt detection
simulation with nic ratio
of 0.25
so with isoc
technologies and this mr pipeline
we analyze the
transcriptome of
breast cancer specimens
in this project eight
estrogen receptor positive breast
8 rna samples from i'm sorry
the rna samples obtained from
8 el positive breast cancer and
14 triple negative breast cancer tnbcs
were analyzed and as a result
about 800 thousands non-redundant
isoforms
were detected from 6 million
consensus sequence
of them uh three hundred and
three hundred thousand isoforms passed
scant filtering
and two hundred sixty thousand
isoforms were unannotated
and 280 000 ice forms
had multiple exons
we identified 3000
unannotated multi-axon genes
and 41 of them were detected
in multiple samples and 10 of them were
annotated in gen called version 28
that we used throughout this project
but they were newly annotated in gen
code
version 34.
further mr transcriptome contains
17 translated but unannotated open
reading frames
identified in a previous report so this
data suggests that mr transcriptome
mr pipeline successfully
captured the
isoforms that are actually present
but unannotated
to assess to see if we used
sufficient number of samples
we incremented the number of samples to
be analyzed
one by one
as shown in the left graph
although the graph did not reach a
plateau
we detected consistent numbers of
isoforms that were detected in more than
80 percent of the samples as shown in
green
and yellow so these
data indicates that we were able to
detect most of the essential
isoforms in contrast
a larger cohort will be required for the
thorough investigations
of the heterogeneity of the isoforms
the scant algorithm
classified the isoforms into nine
categories
as mentioned and
again i will explain isoforms but
categories but
fsm isoform is the full splice match
isoforms and
nic novel in catalog ice forms
uh the isophones uh that contains
novel splicing and splice junctions but
they are composed of
known splicing donuts and spicing accept
us
and now they're not in catalog isoforms
have
nobel spicing donors or novel splicing
acceptors and
we found nic to have the highest number
of isoforms indicating that
the pairing of splicing donor and
splicing acceptors
are far more diverse than registered in
gen code
and the second highest categories
is was nnic
and most of them were detected
only in one sample
but substantial numbers of nnic
were detected in multiple samples
about two about 2700
isoforms were detected in all the
samples
and most of them were categorized as fsm
considering this heterogeneity we
classified
iso forms into four categories
isoforms detected in more than
half of the samples in both subtypes
were defined as unique as shown in
in science in the graphs
isoforms that were detected only in one
subtype
defined as specific as shown in
red and blue
in the graphs isoforms that were
detected only in one sample
are defined as unique as shown in dark
gray in the graphs
and as shown in the right graph
the numbers of
detected unique isoforms
varied between samples depending on the
total numbers of detected isoforms
in contrast there was little variation
in the numbers of common
isoforms
so assuming that sometimes specific
isoforms may contain key molecules
relevant to the breast cancer biology
we try to detect differential transcript
usage genes
genes that use a transcript
differentially between subtypes
and indeed we detected 455
ddu genes including 46
cancer-related genes and 10 breast
cancer related
genes such as esl one
and bcl 11a
so we focused on tns3 genes tensing
tension and tension three genes
first we confirmed that the
noble isoform of tencent three is
specifically
expressed in tnbc as shown
in the black bars in the
right graph by
alti qpcl experiments
as shown in the right panel
tns3 protein
[Music]
contains phosphatase domain and ct
domains and sh2 domains
and reportedly contributes to
cell migration encouraging interventions
growth or
metastasis in several types of cancers
and new isoform we found
in this project is
devoid of phosphates domain and
city domain
[Music]
the novel short form tennessee 3
is transcribed from novel fast
exon
the genomic sequences of the fast
exon is conserved
among the vertebrates and
the peaks of chromatin modifications
associated with promoter function or
enhancer function
were observed uh at the site of this
uh fast axon and
in triple negative breast cancer cell
lines
or normal mammalian eptherium
but they were not observed in el
positive breast cancer cell line
so this data strongly supports the
existence of this
novel short form tn3
to investigate the function of short
form 103
we analyze the gene expression profile
of mcf 10a cells in which into which
a viral vector expressing canonical tns3
or short form tn3 was introduced
and we found that
[Music]
tns3 short form had
impact on gene expression similar to
canonical tns3 but with a greater
effect size
and expression of about 3500 genes were
affected by
short form uh affected by short form
tns3 but
of them at least 900 genes were
only affected by tns3 short form tns3
gene ontology analysis revealed that uh
several features associated with cell
divisions were affected
by both
short form tns 3 and canonical chain 3.
but the effect size is again larger
the effect size of short form gain 3 is
larger than
that of canonical tns3
as shown at the bottom the formation
of stress 5 stress fiber of
actin filament is enhanced in mcf10a
cells
expressing short form
dns 3.
and we also found that the expression of
node 1 node 3
and fgfl3
important drivers are breast cancer is
enhanced
in mcf10a cells expressing short form
tns3
so this data suggests
that short form tns3 has
function distinct from canonical tns3
and implies that dns3
short form may contribute to the
initiation or progression
of breast cancer
we confirm the expression of short form
tn3 in the cancer genome at last cohort
by calculating the percent blasting of
the novel first x
as shown in the right panel
psi is higher in basal type
breast cancer compared to the other
types of
breast cancer
so at last i will talk about the
fusion transcripts
using short read whole genome sequencing
you can quite accurately and sensitively
and detect
structural uh breakpoints of structure
variations
on the other hand by using uh using long
read sequencer
you can accurately analyze the structure
of
fusion transcripts derived from such
rearranged genome of the chemical
isosceles found in
19 bc samples which were previously
subjected to whole genome sequencing we
identified 400 trees with corresponding
dna
breakpoints in whole genome sequencing
data
by analyzing the context and genomic
context
where the detected transcripts
were encoded we found that
uh most five
prime transcript fragments were encoded
in the genic region
in contrast many three prime transcript
fragments
were encoded in the intergenic region or
non-genic region
or we also found that most
transcriptions that site will originate
from
canonical transcriptions that side
also we noticed that most five
prime transcript fragments were
multi-exonic while many
three prime transcript fragments were
monoxonic
so in general we can say that five
prime transcript fragments tends
tends to be regulated by canonical rules
while three prime transcripts fragments
tend to deviate from
the canonical rules
we also detected five non-redundant
trees
that were mapped to three genomic
regions
and at the same time had corresponding
breakpoints
detected in whole genome sequencing data
recently uh pan-cancer analysis of whole
genome pro
consortium reported bridged fusion
which are mapped to two genomic regions
that
are connected by intervening
genomic fragments
double hop fusions we
present here has
internal genomic region of modern
southern
base pairs and some fusion are even
spliced
in these regions this type
of fusion transcripts can't be found
without the long read
transcriptome sequencing
we confirmed the existence of double hop
fusion involving er elv fld1
by sangha sequencing of pcl
amplicons
because uh the full uh
coding sequence of eldfld1
is included in this uh fusion transcript
uh it is considered that the full length
uh elba fld1 protein
is translated was translated
in this sample
and the expression of elbaf rd1
was exclusively detected in the samples
in the sample carrying this fusion
transcript
the expression of uh it is reported
it was reported that erp expression of
elv fld1
is generally suppressed in
across all the tissues except for
placenta
considering the chromatin modification
status
of the genomic
locuses loci
it is highly possible that
the expression of this transcript is
regulated by
the cis regulatory element of
histone 1h
the chromatin modifications
associated with uh promoter y has a
function
was detected in histone one h
c regulatory region in
triple negative breast cancer cell lines
and in normal
anomaly epsilon and these data
suggest suggested the existence of
mechanisms like enhancer hijacking
because it is it was reported that
elv fld1 suppressed the anti-tumor
immune response in allergenic
mouse tumor model so
we measure the growth of tumors
expressing
elv1
in syngenic mass model in which mc38
colon mirroring tumor cells
derived from b6 mice was used
as shown in the left graph
mc38 cells expressing erb fld1
generated larger tumors
than control mc38
cells infected with
empty mock mtb vector
in contrast uh
mc38 cells expressing
elva fld1 and control
mc38 cells generated
[Music]
tumors with similar size so these data
indicated that elba fld1
promoted tumor growth by inhibiting
other human immune response of the host
b6 mice and that enhanced expression of
elv1 in human cancer cells might
contribute to the tumor growth
so in summary we developed
a pipeline for merged samples with
transcriptome assembly musta
to analyze isosic data
musta enabled control
construction of transcriptome from 22
breast cancer clinical specimens
and we identified sometimes specific
isoforms
of genes associated with breast cancer
phenotype
and we also found functional double hop
fusion transcript
that was transcribed from complex
structure rearrangement
so at last i would like to thank many
collaborators
and members of mana lab
and i have to mention that a
major part of this work was done by shin
number who joined our lab as
a undergraduate student
and now he is at
osaka university as a
graduate student so thank you for
listening
and that's it